ready welcome back everyone so we're
very happy to have
froms cool so uh yeah thanks everyone
for being here so you know this is a
very amazing audience it's very humbling
to be here in front of everyone so um
I'm gonna um okay so this talk is about
some work that I did with Luca panti
when he was a master student at hif and
now he's a pH the student in Italy and
we work together on discrep on
discrepancy and yeah uh now I'm I'm
gonna get to tell you a bit about the
work that we did at that point so first
of all let me just like um you know nor
so okay so normally I would talk about
efficient algorithms U so you know this
is not the typical talk that I give so
let's just see how this is going to go
so today's topic is a bit different from
what what I usually do so it's
combinatorial
discrepancy so this is a field of
combinatorics that has seen a lot of
progress coming from the theoretical
computer science
Community uh and you know like there are
many very exciting results you know
within the past years we've seen many
many exciting results that are you know
kind of like made progress on this field
and they're also algorithmically
relevant so let me start by introducing
the classical problem discrepancy which
is Spencer's problem so what is this
problem so imagine that I give you a
ground set of n elements and think of
them as these black points and a family
p of M subsets defined over this ground
set of elements and think of those
subsets as these
ovals my goal is to color each of these
elements in my ground set with one of
two colors either red or blue such that
each set has a balanced coloring
so what does this mean so imagine that
this is going imagine that this is my
coloring now give okay so basically what
I what what I'm trying to do is that I
want to Max to minimize the maximum
imbalance in the sense that I want each
of these sets to you know have roughly
the same number of red elements as blue
elements okay very basic
problem um okay now let me try to
introduce um a bunch of definitions so
basically given a coloring X
and given a set s I'm just going to say
that the discrepancy of that set with
respect to that coloring is the absolute
value of the difference between the
number of blue elements and the number
of red elements right so this set has
discrepancy zero because it's perfectly
balanced so this one this one has
discrepancy two this one has discrepancy
two and this has discrepancy
zero and the discrepancy of the coloring
with respect to the set system is just
going to be the maximum imbalance that
this coloring achieves over all of these
all of these sets in in the system make
sense so far so basically I'm just going
to measure the maximum imbalance among
all of those sets in my family so the
question that we want to answer is you
know how small can we make this
discrepancy well okay do you have like
any
guesses well you know um let me
just uh let me just start by slightly
rephrasing the problem to make it even
more accessible
you know let me just encode each color
with a number that's going to be either
plus one or minus one so basically what
this thing says is that you know I can
just like measure so you know basically
if I just assign a plus one or minus one
to each element in my ground set I can
just measure the discrepancy of a subset
as you know the absolute value of the
sum of the of the sum of these numbers
associated with the elements in my
set which
one right
good okay all right so okay so how do
okay so how small can I make this thing
well you probably already know that the
textbook The Textbook approach tells us
that the first thing we should ever try
is to just throw a random coloring at
our
elements so basically if I hit the
elements from my ground set with some
random plus minus one coloring I can
just start writing basic tail bounds
because you know basically if I just
measure the
discrepancy for a for a fixed subset
that's just going to be a sum of R
random variables and of course for this
I have standard tail bounds so basically
tells me that if I just look at a fixed
subset the
probability that the absolute value of
the sum of these numbers which are
random plusus one numbers is going to
deviate a lot from the mean the probable
that that it's going to be larger than
100 * n log m is going to be pretty
small right so basically so remember
that m is the number of of sets I have
and N is the size of my ground set so
you know basically if I just like you
know basically if I just try to measure
uh if I just try to write the stale
bound you know it say it says that you
know there's a very small chance that
any of that that you know fix that you
know that that the imbalance here
deviates by more than this much and of
course now I can just Union bound over
all of the sets in my system right so
the thing that I have M systems I have M
sets the prob you know the probability
of a bad event for each of them is
bounded by one over two M so you know
basically this just tells me that you
know with probability at least half the
discrepancy is going to be bounded by
order root n logam so everything
standard so far I haven't done anything
too fancy but now the interesting
question appears is this really the best
thing that I can do is it possible you
know like basically here I kind of
ignored correlations between all those
substats in my family right I just
considered them I just looked at each of
them separately I just threw a union
bound at them and this is what I
got well it turns out that you know this
bound of root n log m is not tight in
fact Spencer managed to prove in 85 that
something actually much better can be
achieved right so he managed to prove
that there exists a coloring
that achieves a discrepancy of order
root n log
MN so the case we have to focus on is
the one where m is about the same as n
when m is order n for square matrices in
that case his discre his discrepancy is
order root n and in fact he managed to
prove that this discrepan is at most six
stand six times root 10 so that gave the
name that gave the title of his paper
six standard deviation suffice so this
is kind of puzzling right because you
know I mean Union you know con
concentration bound plus you know plus
Union bound is kind of a standard
technique but he somehow managed to beat
this
thing
so okay so you know like the original I
wanted to mention first that the
original result that Spencer gave was
existential but then following that M
there you know there was a very long
line of works that that derived that
came up with that produced algorithmic
results so notably there uh you know
bansel first pro first first gave some
algorithmic construction and you know uh
I I'm pretty sure that a large number of
the people many people in the audience
have had had worked on some of these
results um now okay I wanted to mention
what why do we even care about you know
we have all of these previous
algorithmic results why do we even care
about you know coming up with yet
another algorithm for discrepancy well
the point is that all many of these
results use prettyy different techniques
and you know while trying to achieve
them they kind of like managed to
uncover a bunch of mathematical
techniques that we can actually use to
prove the existence of rare mathematical
objects which you know it which are hard
to identify by just by just by just
throwing vanilla tools like con like
Union bound so and you know while while
proving these
things a whole bunch of you know a whole
bunch of interesting connections were
made so um so you know it should be I
mean it should you know it should this
effort of studying of studying
discrepancy problem should be worthy
even if we manage to rederive some of
the old results along the
way okay so now um to give yep is this
tight is this what is this me to be
tight oh yeah so this is actually tight
so it's actually quite easy to constru
it's actually quite easy to construct
tight instances so for example the one
one where m is order n is exactly tight
you can just give um you can just give a
scaled Hader Matrix and you know you can
do something similar to prove it for
general for General M yeah thanks
actually think for random sentence type
too yeah that's
you all right now okay now to talk a bit
more about discrepancy and why we care
about it so let me first give you a
slightly cleaner um linear algebraic
view of the problem so so we can do this
thing by encoding our set system into a
matrix that's going to be M byn so each
of the Matrix is going to correspond to
a set each column is going to cont
correspond to an element and I'm gonna
and basically I'm just you know
basically each row is going to be the
characteristic Vector of you you know of
a set of a set for my system right so
basically for so basically for the I set
in my system SI on the I row of the
Matrix I'm going to put a one on column
J if that if element J belongs to the
set and the zero
otherwise so then I can just like see
what happens when I hit this Matrix with
a vector that encodes my coloring right
basically I'm just go you know I just
like compute a times x and I'm going to
get some I'm going to get some as an
output a vector where each where the
elements encode you know the absolute
value of these elements in code the
discrepancies that this coloring gives
me for each of these
sets right so basic basally you know
using this lar algebraic view we we can
see that the discrepancy of a coloring X
is just going to be the infinity Norm of
ax good now this is not the only problem
that people care about there are a bunch
of other very interesting regimes
notably the first one we care about is
the back fala problem which is quite
interesting so basically it's a it's a
very particular instance where each
column has bounded sparcity it has at
most s nonzeros and in fact for such
instances you know people were managed
to achieve much to achieve much better
discrepancy bounds they managed to prove
that you know for such instances one can
achieve a discrepancy of order s so know
that this is independent of n or square
root as log
n so you know like basically this one is
independent of n whereas um independent
of the number of columns where whereas
this one has a better dependence on S
but depends l ially on the number of
columns of my Matrix and of course it's
conjecture that you know one can
actually achieve a discrepancy bound of
order square root S but in fact not even
s 2.99 is known so if you manage to
prove anything like that that'd be a
pretty major
breakthrough and okay so this is the be
fiala problem and there's actually a an
a further extension which is even even
more interesting which is the commos
problem so here my Matrix is just going
to be a real Matrix and my columns are
going to be real vectors whose L2 Norm
is bounded by
one and it's actually so you know so
basically in this case what we're trying
to do is that essentially we're just
like trying to you know trying to come
up with a you know we're trying to find
signs for all of these column vectors
that are bounded in L2 nor by one such
that you know their their sign sum has
small L Infinity norm and in fact using
a whole bunch of you know you know
pretty clever convex
geometry bastic originally managed to
prove that one can achieve a discrepancy
of order square root log n and of course
it's conjecture that one can achieve a
discrepancy of order
one and note that this problem is
actually much stronger than be fala
because it implies be fiala right if you
give me an instance of be fala I can
just scale down my input by a factor of
one / root S I get a comos instance
whatever discrepancy I get for for the
commos problem translates into a
discrepancy B for back f scale by a
factor of root S right so like root log
and discrepancy for comos implies R Tes
L again for be FAL already and if anyone
manages to prove this thing you know we
also get what we're hoping to get over
here so now the thing that you know like
this is like a pretty exciting problem
like the way the way people manage to
prove things like this you know like
banasik used a bunch of very some
ingenious convex geometry and you know
this is also kind of like related to the
suprema of raher processes which is
something that tegrant worked on very
hard so you know it's actually so you
know it's actually quite it's actually
quite interesting there are many
interesting connections to draw from
studying these problems now okay so we
can we can move on and talk about this
thing a bit
later um you know uh I wanted to just
like move on a bit and just go to the
objective of the stock so the objective
of the stock will be twof folded
so first I want to present you a very s
simple algorithm that basically that
that you know that gives yet another
constructive method for proving Spencer
theorem and it's kind of nice because
it's based on Newtons method which is
some optimization method that optimizers
like to use a lot it's it's very common
in fact using this method we can
actually you know we can actually
improve the constant in Spencer bound so
we can prove that 3.67 stand deviation
suffice um so this is nice um but you
know but but but you know like even
further we can kind of like use the
these techniques together with um with
together with some idea um put forth by
potukuchi where he was trying to
actually prove that uh the Kos
conjecture is is true for pseudorandom
matrices so basically we manag to prove
that for the right notion of PUD
Randomness but we one can actually prove
a discrepancy of order one for comlo
instances and the way this thing is done
you know is basically we can like build
on some idea you know that potukuchi
used to prove uh you know the
corresponding version for the case of
the back fi
problem um so and you know like while so
I'm G to start by presenting you this
algorithm and what's going to be nice
about it is that it's also going to
highlight a bunch of interesting
obstacles that appear when whenever we
try to prove these more interesting
conjectures do you have any yeah it
seems is it true that for random
instances it was known that Comm
conjecture holds with the
constant U so I don't I'm not sure I
don't think that anyone knew how to
prove this thing before oh I see okay so
basically your proof is the first that
establishes this for random as well yeah
so I mean you can do it for all sorts of
interest you know interesting sud random
instances you know so like specifically
there's this example that I find very
difficult which is you know just
rotation
matrices if you manage to prove anything
about that in the worst case you're
probably making you're probably got to
make a lot of progress towards uh you
know towards this conure in general we
at least managed to prove it for random
rotations all right so let me just um so
let me just move to uh describing the
algorithm we use for proving
Spenser so basically the AL the algorith
follows the blueprint of other similar
algorithms such as the one of lat Mecca
and pl ramadas
Ros um so which is based on you know
kind of like it you know constructing a
fractional coloring you know basically
you know constructing a fractional
fractional coloring that we kind of keep
evolving what by by moving a part
particle through the through the unit
hyper Cube until we eventually hit a
corner which is going to give our
solution so to okay now okay now to to
make it easier to understand the
algorithm and the analysis let me just
slightly simplify the objective so
instead of uh looking at the L Infinity
Norm of the Matrix ax let me just try to
look at the maximum maximum value of
Maximum entry in ax and I can do this
thing very easily you know I can just
like stack a on top of minus a and just
like you know try to find the coloring X
for which Maximum of this new Matrix
time x is going to be bounded
good all right so again we interpret the
thought
coloring which is a plus minus one
vector as a vertex of this of this unit
hyper Cube and again like to con and
again to construct this coloring we
start with some point at zero and then
we iteratively move it through this
hyper Cube until we eventually hit a
corner now in order to be able to do
this thing we need to enforce a bunch of
invariance
one of them is that uh at every single
step I'm just gonna the way I'm going to
update my current point is that I'm
going to update it with some dire in
some direction Delta that's orthogonal
to my current position X and the reason
why I do this thing is that because this
enforces some sort of monotonicity
because it enfor forces the for forces
the invariant that the squared L2 Norm
of my current Point always increases is
monotonically increases increasing and
the other thing that I'm going to
enforce is that once my point hits a
face of the hyper Cube I just freeze
that coordinate that hit hits the face
of the coordinate I never change it
again so that means that in the long run
you know I just keep increasing the
squar L2 Norm of my X eventually it hits
a you know it hits a face of the hyper
Cube so it freezes that coordinate and
it keeps doing this thing until the
square al2 Norm becomes n which means
that I found a corner of the hyper Cube
and that's going to be the coloring I
return
okay now okay so okay so this is what I
need to enforce in order to make sure
that I return a coloring now the
difficult thing is that as I evolve this
fractional coloring I really need to
control the growth of this function
which is the max of
ax now this is going to be a bit
annoying because the maximum function is
a nasty function it's not even
continuously differentiable and you know
it's kind of hard to try Evolution as I
change
X so what I do instead of directly
tracking it is something that you know
is something that we like to do a lot
which is to just replace this maximum
function with a smooth approximation Fe
and how I come up with the smooth
approximation you know what smooth
approximation of the maximum function I
use here is really going to determine
the outcome you know what you know the
outcome of this algorithm the
discrepancy bound I manag to
prove so
basically I'm going to do a brief
interlude uh so to show you how to
derive such smooth approximations and
the answer comes from convex analysis
where a standard way to make an SD
function smooth is this technique called
regularization so okay and we're going
to do this thing in two steps so first
let me just write the maximum function
as the linear optimization problem over
the unit Simplex so basically if I just
want to if I want to the maximum of some
Vector Y what I really want to do is
that you know I want I'm going to cast
this fingers finding the vector P
defined on the unit Simplex that
maximizes the inner product between y
and p now you know this is not something
very clever because you know at because
the the P that I want to produce is
going to be supported at a single
coordinate it's just going to hit
exactly the largest coordinate in
y but what I can do is that I can just
fix this thing by by adding a
regularization term Omega which is going
to be you know which is going to be some
nice convex function which is going to
which is basically going to penalize me
whenever whenever the speed is very
spiky so so it's going to encourage me
to kind of more unifor uniformly
distribute the mass over this over the
speed that I use it to hit my y now the
effect of this is going to be now the
effect of this is going to be that it's
basically going to run the corner the
corners of this function so for example
you know you can just thereare this plot
this is going to be the maximum function
plotted in you know um you know for two
dimensional vectors this is going to be
the regularize maximum that I obtain if
I just like throw some nice convex
function on top of
this and actually there are some very
standard choices of regularizers that
people use one of them that's very
standard is negative entropy basically
if I just you know if I just hit if I
just hit this p with the negative
entropy function what I'm going to get
is going to be this smooth approximation
of the maximum function which is log sum
of exponentials which you know is
exactly what we are analyzing whenever
we studied the multiplicative weights
update method or whenever we try to do
randomize turn not
bounce now okay so this one shows very
naturally shows up very naturally and
you're very familiar with it now the one
that we're going to be using here is
going to be a bit more funky uh so it's
going to be this Square regularizer
U which uh looks a bit difference is
basically just going to be determined by
a sum of square roots of entries of the
vector P of this SP distribution P now
when I explicitly write down what this
you know I explicitly write down the
smooth approximation fee that I obtain
by using this regular Riser I'm going to
get something that looks a bit funny
it's it's going to be a bit interesting
to parse it so it's basically going to
be you know a scalar you know it's going
to be the result of a scalar
minimization
problem where the where the scaler here
Lambda is going to achieve a trade-off
between two terms on the one hand I want
this Lambda to be larger than the
maximum value of y but of course I don't
want it to be too large because you know
I mean because if it's too large then
you know the value you know then then
you know this term is going to
contribute a lot on the other hand I
have this other term which basically
penalizes me whenever Lambda becomes
very close to gets very close to any of
the entries of my Vector so in some
sense this acts as some sort of barrier
term which basically says okay well I
want I could you know I want this thing
I want to make this thing as small as
possible Right while being at least as
large as the maximum entry of Y but I
don't want to make it very small so this
is going to you know this is going to
repel this is going to this is going to
repel me from the largest
entry now as weird as this may look this
actually this is actually a nice and
different you know this is going to be a
nice differentiable function that's
going to have that that that has nice
that has nice gradients so there you
know there that that's going to have
nice ellipses gradients and this is
exactly what we're going to be use that
what we're going to be using
here um
okay
so okay now the thing is that
okay now okay what we managed to achieve
by introduc by introducing this
regularization term was that it helped
us turn this maximum function into a
nice function that's continuously
differentiable and has you know has nice
properties on the other
hand well we have to pay something in
exchange because you know we are
modifying our function so we introduce a
bunch of air so we need to pay up for
this error up front so this is going to
int you know and we need to control this
air but in exchange you know we get the
nice differentiability properties now
this air is kind of important because um
you know it really depends on the choice
of regularizer we use and we're going to
get uh we're going to get back to that
in a bit now let me um
okay okay now let me try um now let me
try to go over let me try to go over the
the good things you know what the good
things that follow from regular from
regularization well once we regularize a
function once we once we compute this
regularized maximum now all of a sudden
it becomes differentiable and has nice
properties and we can just track how it
evolves when we make a tiny update right
basically if I move from y to Y plus
some Delta I can just measure how much
my new regularized maximum will be
compared to the old one by you know just
looking at the first order term which is
going to be the inner product between
the gradient you know the gradient of
this the gradient of this Fe which
actually happens to be exactly the
probable distribution that achieves the
argmax over
here there's going to be a second order
term that involves a quadr you know that
that um involves a quadratic function uh
with the H of this regular maximum which
is just like you know something that
depends on my probable distribution p
and some higher order
terms okay so it has nice properties
it's differentiable and everything now
the thing is that what's going to be
very important is that once I look at
the second order term its contribution
really depends on the choice of my
regularizer so for example in the case
of negative entropy basically I can just
bound the contribution of the second
order term by the inner product between
my Pro distribution p and the pointwise
squared um the pointwise squared Vector
Delta that I used to move that I used to
update my current
y now whenever I use the other
regularizer the square root regularizer
this thing actually becomes much more
tame because I can actually bound the
second order term by something that you
know involves the inner product between
you know the point Y squ update Delta
and this probable distribution to to
power three halves so you know while in
the worst case when p is very spiky
there's no big difference between these
two imagine the case when this is
uniform when this is relatively uniform
in this case this is actually much
smaller it can be a smaller by of like
one over root n so basically what I
managed to what I managed to buy Here by
using a different regularizer is that I
can actually I can actually control the
growth of this regularized maximum much
better what I pay for it in exchange is
that is the is the error that I
introduce while in the case of negative
entropy the eror I introduce is going to
be B is going to be log n in the case of
this square regularizer is going to be
something that's going to be order root
n so this so you know so this is the
kind so you know so this is the kind of
tradeoff that you I mean so this is the
kind of trade-off that you achieve but
for our purposes this is actually going
to be much more
useful
okay so okay so I so I I defined the
smooth approximation of Max that we're
going to be
using so okay so all we have all we have
left to do now is to control the speed
of increase of our regularized maximum
fee right so basically uh what we're
going to try to do um you know whenever
whenever we move from X to X Plus Delta
right uh now we know exactly that the
squared L2 Norm of our of our iterate is
going to increase by precise this Square
to Norm of Delta what we're going to try
to control will be the ratio you know
the ratio of the change in my
regularized maximum fee versus the
change in the squared lorm of my atate
right this is what I'm going to call
speed now using taor expansion I know
that this change in fee is going to be
given by this linear term plus quadratic
term plus higher order terms and you
know just and you know I know that you
know this difference is just going to be
exactly given by the square Al to Norm
of my update Delta now of course when I
take very small step very small steps
this high order term does not really
matter just it's just G to go to zero so
all I need to focus on is just these F
these you know is just this the first
order term and the second order term
okay so basically what this thing tells
us is that if we want to control the
speed of increase of fee what we need to
control is really you know this qu you
know this quadratic
function so okay so basically how do we
so okay so basically okay now how now
this adest now this suggest a now this
already suggests the kind of Step that
you want to take basically it's saying
that well what's the best direction that
I you know what's the direction that I
want to take if I want to increase the
square Delta Norm of of my iterate
without increasing without increasing my
Fe too much well basically I can just
find that direction by just like solving
by by Just Trying to minimize this
quadratic uh over the set of iterates
that are perpendicular to my current X
because I want to maintain the IM
variant which tells me that you know I
always increase my squel to Norm so you
know this is this is basically just a
Newton
step now of
course you know um generally if you just
so basically what I can do in continuous
you know in continuous time I can just
solve a sequence of quadratic
minimization problems of this type of
course I I want to always move only you
know basically I only want to update the
coordinance of X that are not frozen yet
right so I just need to restrict the
support of my Delta and I want it to be
orthogonal to my current X but now the
so now the point is that if I look at
this thing you know generic
generically you know if I did not have
this constraint generically I can make
this quadratic negative so that can only
give my that can only give me progress
of course I can run into trouble
whenever you know this linear term that
I used to hit Delta with a transpose
times p is perfect perfectly aligned
with X so in that case I really need to
move orthogonal to this linear term so I
just need to move orthogonal to a
transpose P so it means that I must make
this linear term equal to zero and at
that point I really need to worry about
the contribution of this higher order
term
okay so basically what does this uh so
you know so basically it tells me that
in order to be able to control the speed
I really need to you know try to
understand you know I really you know I
really need to understand how small I
can make this
quadratic okay now to do this thing
we're going to use the LMA which says
that whenever you know whenever we have
K VAR Ables
available um you know so basic so
remember that at you know remember that
you know I execute my algorithm some
algorithms get get frozen I never touch
them again and you know I'm just
imagining that I have I still have K
directions left to move right so I have
Frozen all but K
variables so basically what we what we
prove is that whenever we have K of K
variables left available in the support
we can bound the speed of increase by
order one over root K and we're going to
get back to we're going to get back to
this in a
bit so the proof idea is to basically
show that this Matrix has a small igon
value in the Subspace that's orthogonal
to to X because you know remember that I
don't want to touch I you know I mean
you know I may I I'm not I'm not I'm not
allowed to touch that Subspace and
though I do that is basically I just
bound the trace of this Matrix over that
Subspace and yeah I'm G to show you an
idea I'm gonna show you how to do this
thing in a bit now the thing is that
once I have this LMA you know I can just
move I can just move to the end game
because I can do this thing to kind of
to measure the total increase in fee I
suffer from the from from from the
beginning of the algorithm all the way
to the
end well the so let's just imagine
what's happening like originally I have
n unfrozen coordinates so basically I
have n degrees of freedom
so using this LMA it tells me that you
know for as long as this happens you
know the speed of increase is going to
be one over root n which is very small
which is so that so it tells me that Fe
increases relatively slowly now what can
happen in the worst case is that I just
keep increasing X until its Square Delta
Norm becomes exactly one and just
happens that it had Frozen a
coordinate right at that point I have n
minus one coordinates left available and
at that point the speed of increase of
Fe BEC slightly larger becomes 1/ root n
minus one so if I just look at this
worst case Behavior tells me that okay
well in the worst case the increase in
my in my in my fee is going to be at
most order one / root n plus one/ root n
minus one and so on and this is just
going to be something that's about order
square root n so that tells me that you
know from the beginning to the end of
the algorithm my smooth approximation to
my maximum
function has increased by by about or
the RO n but remember
now that you know like this Fe at zero
was not zero right I must pay something
in exchange for for in exchange for
getting this smooth this this nice
smooth approximation of the maximum
function remember that my function you
know basically at
um you know basically at zero the value
of f of Z is going to be the maximizer
of this linear term which is going to be
0 minus Omega of P
over PS in the on the unit simplex and
basically this just gets maximized one p
uniform and charges me exactly two *
root 10
so combining these two things combining
these two facts the bound on fee at
initialization plus the bound on the
total increase in fee over the course of
my algorithm I managed to show that by
the end the max you know the value of my
final fee which is going to Upper bound
the value of the maximum of ax is going
to be at most order Ro 10 and that's
it um okay now I can if you're
interested I can give you a brief idea
for how to Pro how to prove this thing
like the idea is that you know basically
what we're really trying to do is that
we're trying to show that this
Matrix
um that this Matrix that we very that
that you know that this Matrix has a
small igon value in the Subspace
orthogonal to X but of course you know
after I restrict myself to you know just
like the coordinates that I can still
move that I can still update so let me
just look at the Matrix
QX which is going to be the Matrix a
restricted to the columns s that are
still
unfrozen Columns of
a that are still
unfrozen
and let me assume that at this point the
size of s is equal to K so now my my
Matrix is going to be something like a
restricted to this column I just throw
everything else away
transpose um okay I can just like
spectrally upper bound it times diagonal
of some probable of some probable
distribution P which is exactly the prob
distribution that shows up over here
time
a and what I want to prove is
that
QX has a
small ion
value in the Subspace orthogonal to
X now okay well how do I how do I prove
the existence of a small igon value for
this Matrix well the simplest thing I
can possibly do is to just bound the
trace of Q of X right well if I because
I know that the trace of Q is just the
the sum of its igon values and it has K
igon values and the trace is basically
just going to be the sum over all
pis
times squared L2 Norm of rows of the
Matrix and okay uh The crucial thing is
that you know once I use this magical
regularizer this square root regularizer
this is actually raised to the power
three
Hales okay now the thing is that because
my Matrix contains entries that are
bounded by one in Infinity norm and here
I have only K columns available I know
that each of these terms is going to be
upper bounded by Case by K right it's
just going to be a vector that's going
to be B that has entries at most one
which has Dimension k
so you know so basically this tells me
that definitely the smallest igon so I
mean okay not only the smallest igon
value but you know like you know half of
the igon values of this guy are going to
be at most order Trace over K so
basically it tells me that you know
um so I know that my Lambda Min for
example is going to be at most 1 /k *
this whole thing times the sum of my
P now the things that typically I can't
say anything interesting about this
thing because again like if my if this
par distribution were spiky this can be
as bad as one but now let me just
imagine this wishful thinking scenario
where this thing is rather uniform so
let me just imagine that I'm in the case
where you know where all these pis are
maybe order one over K in this case I
get something much better because I can
make the sum you know because once you
know what's the what's the possible
worst case for the sum is going to be
when there are going to be exactly order
K components in this Vector that are
going to be as large as possible so this
is going to make you know the sum to be
bounded by K * 1 over K to three halves
which is basically you know one/ root K
so I get so in that case I would in this
Wishful in this wishful thinking
scenario I get something amazing
now of course the problem is that it's
it will not always be the case that my
Pi is going to be so uniform but the
thing that you know like all I'm trying
to achieve is to kind of like prove that
this Matrix has a you know has a pretty
has a has a pretty small igon value and
the thing is that you know like the
stress argument is kind of weak because
you know I'm just like looking you know
I'm just like I'm just like looking at
all the Subspace and I'm just doing the
dumbest possible averaging what I can do
is to basically just say okay
well let me you know let me let me try
to ignore the Subspace you know that
spanned by the rows of this by the rows
of this Matrix that that correspond to
the largest K over two entries in in in
this Vector P well once I do that
basically what I did was that I just
threw away K over two k over two
directions in which I can possibly move
but then all the remaining PS are going
to be bounded by order one over k so
that basically means that you know this
is go this is going to enable me to
certify that within that
Subspace my Trace is small and therefore
I have a small igon value which is going
to be as small as I want it to be order
one over root K so that's basically how
you end how how you get to prove this
slma
okay so basically this pretty much wraps
up the proof for
Spencer but and you know we Pro that you
know we have this nice continuous
Dynamic that yields a good coloring and
if you just analyze everything very
carefully you prove you improve on
spener constant you prove that 3.67
standard deviations of ice this is
probably not tight I think it's kind of
conjecture that the right constant
should be two but um someone probably
needs to work harder to prove that thing
but of course you know like yeah um
could you just remind me the
the the update Delta are you adding it
in with a random sign or is the sign
coming from the optimization oh I mean
the point is that you can always choose
the sign to make this thing negative
right I mean the sign always comes from
solving this optimization problem you
know typically you know the only if you
did not have this constraint you could
always make this whole thing negative
now just because you have this annoying
constraint that you you actually want to
make progress you want to move
orthogonal to your current X well it may
just happen that you know you're you're
going to this is going to force you to
make this term zero and at that point
you know you just need to worry about
your
quadratic but yeah I mean you're always
free to choose the sign okay thank
thanks okay so um okay so basically we
can just like test our tools to try to
prove something harder like maybe the
comos conjecture the problem is that for
matrices you know for for matric you
know for matrices of this type we can
only certify weaker bounds on this
second smallest igon value of our Matrix
Q of X the thing is that the key
difficulty here is that in Spencer
instances the mass on the rows of a is
very uniformly spread so basically what
happens is that you know we have our
Matrix initially you know like each you
know each row has Z you know each row
has entries that are at most
one in absolute value and then the thing
that I keep I start freezing freezing I
start freezing some of these elements
now the thing is that the remaining Mass
keeps decreasing so depending on how
many variables I still have left
available you know that's that's going
to give me a bound on the mass I still
have available on the rows on the on
those rows so this uniform spread is
kind of un is kind of essential to be
able to prove things in this situation
uh could I ask something yep um I so I
thought if I understood correctly your
algorithm for Spencer does not ever do a
partial coloring it kind of just gets a
full coloring in one shot could you
speak that yeah okay so that's a very
good point so it doesn't worry about
partial colorings but the thing is that
it still suffers from the curse of
partial colorings in the sense that you
know basically whatever you pay for
before you manage to freeze half of the
coordinates is going to dominate
whatever you end up paying in the future
now the problem is that once you look at
problems like the Kos problem is that
okay you pay something you pay one until
you freeze half of the variables but
then the speed of you know the speed at
which your fee increases is going to
double so the thing so so the point is
that you know now I you know these
things increase twice the speed and
that's how I I end up accumulating some
extra log which is going to be very
annoying so basically to be able to get
rid of this thing you kind of need to
somehow take advant you know you kind of
need to leverage this sort of uniform
spread property which really does not
come for free because like the reason is
that you know like basically you can
just try to look at you know dispenser
instance so you know you can just
measure the speed initially it's going
to be bounded by you know one/ root five
then one over root four one over root
three and you get exactly what you need
if you want to replicate this sort of
behavior for a commos instance you
really want to get some much tighter
bounds you know uh the things that such
things are not possible because it may
just happen that you you might actually
have a whole bunch of rows of your
Matrix
that really contain a lot of mass so
that's so you know so that's not really
going to work I mean basically if you
wanted to be able to get the same type
of bound over here you really need
needed to you
know always be able to say that you know
at all point you know at all times you
know all of my remaining rows have you
know have have some you know have have
like some very small amount of mass
that's not even true in the
beginning now the problem is that okay
so y so this seems like the more
interesting obstacle but you also have
an obstacle in the initialization right
uh what's the obstacle the constant root
n that you get out of the sure but you
can you can vary your regularizer so the
things that okay so that's just an
example that I use specifically for the
N byend Spenser instance even when you
when you have a you know a different M *
10 you know I use a different type of
regular it's not going to be square root
it's going to be you know like it's
going to be it's going to be X to some
power so that I need to choose
carefully and you know like yeah so I
mean I I mean I agree with you like the
point is that you know I mean ideally I
would have liked to be able to use the
same type of regularizer just like pay a
root and up front and then just multiply
it you and then just like you know take
you know just like
okay I would just wanted to pay a root
and up front so okay the things that
okay you can always put like some weight
on your regularizer so maybe I can scale
it down and in exchange you know I pay
more for the speed so in the end you end
up paying something like the geometric
mean between how much your regularizer
contributes at zero and you know how
much you pay for this you know because
of you know for this you know for the
speed of increase of your U of your fee
now the point is that if somehow I
manage to control you know like the
spread of these rows then I would have
gotten exactly what I needed and this is
not generically true but the thing is
that this kind of condition does
actually hold for random matrices like
basically for random matrices actually
you know like if you know if I just
generate I you know for example I just
like each of these elements is some IID
gaussian for example I get exactly what
I need more or less and you know like
basically POI introduced some pseud
Randomness condition that he used to
actually he used for um you know for the
back fala problem and you know basically
if we just like work our way around that
sort of sud Randomness condition we
pretty much exactly get what we need we
get exactly the type you know we get
some sort of uniform spread module some
rows that are going to cause us some
trouble but we need to be but we can
just ignore them temporarily and get get
back to them later uh now formally what
does this sud Randomness condition what
is this sud Randomness condition that
I'm talking about it's basically looking
at something like this imagine that a is
my
Matrix and I'm going to look at the
maximum over all vectors orthogonal to
the old ones Vector of the L2 Norm of my
Matrix Point y^ SAR time V divided by
the al2 norm of V so this thing is kind
of I mean you know let's just like try
to understand this thing for example in
the case when a is some is a symmet is a
symmetric comos Matrix for example let
just imagine that you know all the all
the rows have L2 Norm exactly one and
let me also make make it
symmetric in this case this point Y
squared Matrix is just going to be a
random walk Matrix
right and I know just from Pon forus
that you know the Old One's Vector is
just going is just going to be the
largest it's just going to be you know
the the largest igon Vector so basically
what this thing is essentially measuring
is going to be the spectral Gap right
when I have a large spectral Gap this
Lambda is actually going to be is is
going to be small right so what we're
proving here is that when we have a huge
spectral gap which corresponds to the
case where this looks very random we
actually get something better than
vanilla than you know the current you
know the current bounds that are known
from commos right we get the discrepancy
of like 1 plus Lambda l n so when Lambda
is like significantly smaller than one
we actually manag to get an
improvement and for example in the
special case of random rotation matrices
this is actually very small it's
actually something like one over root 10
so in that case you actually get
discrepancy order one and you know there
are a whole bunch of other examples
where this thing
works now of course it'd be kind of
interesting to go beyond these random
instances um so again I'd be very
curious to understand you know just what
happens for the case of rotations but in
the worst case
um I was talking you know um just
yesterday I think thatan was mentioning
that if you manage to prove anything
like that for worst case rotations that
already implies some very interesting
facts facts about lates so the so so you
know that's probably the first problem
you want to look at if you're trying to
attack this
conjecture now I guess it's kind of time
to wrap up so basically what we did was
that um you know we used some
interesting
regularization to solve problems in
combinatorics and we managed to simplify
many results because I think that the
algorithm is extremely small is
extremely simple right just execute a
sequence of Newton methods of Newton's
method and you're
done uh so we managed to strengthen
generalize Poes result and we Pro that
kush actually holds for interesting
random instances which also happens to
refute some paper that was uh the
conjecture that was put forth in some
paper who that was kind of trying to
argue
that okay basically there were okay
there was like some Pap there was like
some older paper that was kind of trying
to argue things about the density of um
good col um of the density of good
colorings for comos instances and
basically that paper was roughly
conjecturing that random
instances that could random rotations
could actually be a hard example for
commo and it's actually not and you know
uh there's some interesting food for
thought which is just trying to prove
something about you know worst case
instances not random and we have like
these very structured worst case
instances just some fixed
rotation has a very nice geomet you know
very nice GE geometric statement
basically says that no matter how you
rotate an n-dimensional hyper Cube
you're always going to have a Vertex
that's close to the origin in L Infinity
Norm so if you managed to prove that you
know that'd be huge progress so yeah
that's about it for now
[Applause]
what is the ultimate runtime that you
get oh good question say for B okay so
this is not gonna be a fast algorithm
right so for example if you execute this
thing I think you I mean you can do it
in something like ow steps and I mean if
you don't do anything too too smart I
know you probably get something like n
Omega plus
one it's not great I mean I think that
uh Yang and some other people already
have something that runs in input
sparity time for SP you know for for
Spencer and stuff like that so I mean
there's defin there are definitely other
works that achieve fast algorithms but
they use but they use different
methods thanks so you know I'm more
concerned with you know uh the
existential aspects than the
constructive ones as far as discrepancy
goes you alluded to a connection to
Lates at the very end if you can you say
something about about the conjecture
there okay I can't say anything has I
can't say anything specific I think that
there are people here who are experts in
lates I don't want go there but I mean
you know I think that if you stare hard
at them I mean probably going to I lce
is kind of pop up naturally I don't like
maybe someone else can say something
yeah it looks this looks very connected
to lce problems but I was just wondering
if there yeah some specific technical
connection yeah I'm not sure
okay just a more General version of my
question of runtime I know that I think
a balanced walk gives a linear time
algorithm for basuk theorem but is it
the only approach um basically what what
are the it's not immediately related to
your talk but what are the currently
known approaches for U producing bonash
chuk style uh colorings in linear time
in the linear time current in the input
size okay is it just balanced walk or is
it is there more get right bounding I
don't know how I don't care about poly
logs let's say with polylog I
think probably running something like
that with Spencer like yeah so only
balanced walk and der oh so you're
saying that like if you want to get
Square log nothing fast is no or yeah I
think so square root log nothing's know
log you can probably run like some
algorithm for Spencer and there's like a
partial coloring is already gonna give
you the log if you want to so you know
whatever works for Spencer is gonna work
for for con more or
less
ask
um so uh on your previous slide when you
said you got the bound of 1 plus o of
root Lambda log N is a true that
lambda's I just I it seems like lambda's
always at most one so it does generalize
but okay so you have to be careful so I
mean here okay uh wait sorry can you say
that again is it true that Lambda is
always at most one so okay if your
Matrix is symmetric it is true right
just because for forus whatever if it's
not I mean it can actually be larger but
you know like for in cases you
know you know whenever this is random
random it's going to be below one got it
I guess I was just asking whether this
theorem generalizes like whether your
techniques given alternate proof of bash
bound oh I guess that that's the I think
that you probably need to work a bit
harder I mean like I think that you know
the kind you know this kind of you know
this is like probably not exactly the
right condition you want here you
probably want to relate this thing
directly the spectral gap of this Matrix
like this whole Vector is kind of a
stupid choice so we can work around it I
mean my bet is that it's going to work
if
you any
El and we have a 30 minute break and